bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo 45 minutes d'information
politique et parlementaire avec michaël
szames s vosges à catllar bonjour
michael oui ou non à l'unité de la
gauche pour les élections régionales
c'est la question posée par le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste qui a
annoncé un référendum sur la question il
aura lieu entre le 16 et le 18 octobre
sur les marchés et en ligne un message à
l'autre gauche qui suscite réserves et
critiques
de leur côté les républicains ont obtenu
leurs journées parlementaires nicolas
sarkozy a tenté de préserver l'unité
jusqu'aux régionales après nature
viendra le temps des primaires et puis
on parlera des projets d'anne hidalgo
qui souhaitent plus de pouvoirs pour
réorganiser la capitale elle veut
notamment redessiné la carte des
arrondissements et fusionner la ville et
le département
cette actualité est notre invité sera
bien sûr pour ce nous accompagner jean
marie le guen bonjour bonjour secrétaire
d'état en charge des relations avec le
parlement je lui ai dit vous allez
développer toute cette actualité on va
commencer bien entendu par le lundi avec
cette consultation voulue par le parti
socialiste consultation parce que
référendum
le référendum du peuple de gauche au
fond de divisions avec les verts à moins
de trois mois des élections régionales
et bien jean christophe cambadélis
cette composition elle a été fortement
critiquée rejeté aussi par une partie de
ses partenaires on voit tout cela avec
jérôme bonnard samedi soir l'annoncé
surprise d'une consultation citoyenne
sur l'unité de la gauche aux régionales
avait des allures de sos
aidez nous à réaliser l'unité parce que
celle ci est nécessaire face au bloc
réactionnaire qui se constituent entre
le front national et le parti
républicain
oui ou non à l'unité des partis de
gauche aux régionales
le référendum proposé par jean
christophe cambadélis est loin de faire
l'unanimité chez les communistes le
front de gauche et les écologistes en
rupture avec la politique actuelle du
gouvernement il est hors de question de
s'associer aux socialistes dans les
perspectives des élections régionales
pour les verts le constat est
irréversible c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait de la politique ça c'est un petit
coup partisans fébriles on a discuté on
n'a pas le même projet donc aller devant
les électeurs pour défendre un projet
alors que on ne partage pas ça fait
plutôt monter l'abstention
moi je rêve juste une chose c'est de
pouvoir présenter le projet écologiste
aux électeurs et qui tranche
à moins de trois mois des régionales où
le ps est en mauvaise posture
les alliés fidèles se font de plus en
plus rares parmi eux les radicaux de
gauche présents hier à montpellier où il
tenait leur 100ème congrès manuel valls
a exhorté ses alliés à une unité seul
capable selon le premier ministre
d'éviter une nouvelle déconvenue
électorale alors fait que mme ait obtenu
par la négociation vous espérer l'avoir
par la rue par les urnes pourrait dire
ça on pourrait dire tout simplement que
il ya aujourd'hui à gauche de la gauche
comme l'on dit dans cette gauche
radicale à la fois
surenchère permanente dans la critique
et puis deuxièmement une segmentation à
l'infini parce que vous alliez vous
perdez les verts dont les verts superbe
ce que je constate c'est que aujourd'hui
les verts sont perdus et avec google
comme une croix définitive sur ce
dossier non non mais pas du tout je
pense que si vous voulez on constate la
fragmentation aujourd'hui vous seriez
bien en peine de compter la
fragmentation de tous les morceaux de
verre qui existe et que si je continuais
comme cela on pourrait aller à
l'intérieur du front de gauche les
positions de monsieur laurent les
positions de monsieur mélenchon bon bref
il ya une fragmentation complète mais
avec un discours qui est assez réaliste
à la fois que je le disais de surenchère
et puis aussi de d'attaqués d'agressions
vis-à-vis du parti socialiste et dox
donc ce référendum vous n'avez pas peur
du résultat jean marie le guen vous irez
d'ailleurs écouter c'est un enjeu est ce
que le peuple de gauche qui est
profondément attaché il le monde dans
les sondages dans les témoignages que
nous avons à l'unité et bien va dire à
ceux qui sont pour la division écouter
d'accord vous avez des différences
personne ne veniez des différences mais
devant l'essentiel est aujourd'hui le
moment de l'essentiel est venu on se
rassemble mais je n'ai pas de doute que
certains refuseront parce que il y as on
le voit bien depuis des années il ya
encore une fois des gens qui sont partis
dans le sectarisme dans l'oubli il était
prenons un exemple vous avez on a tous
vécu ça la sphère de la grèce il ya
trois mois monsieur mélenchon d'autres
nous disait à cette extraordinaire
monsieur tsipras ce c'est l'homme de la
situation en europe il va bouleverser la
situation européenne
je ne suis pas assez rentré en
responsables de son gouvernement il a
mené des discussions qui sont
extrêmement difficile et s'est colleté
aux réalités qu'on dise mêmes gens or
monsieur tsipras c'est un traître
il faut absolument soutenir ceux qui le
contestent ceux qui le contestent avait
d'autre but que de faire chuter monsieur
de sipera ce et donc par te faire
arriver la droite laissez-moi terminé 7e
anecdote qui n'en est pas une qui est
très illustrative et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé monsieur tsipras a gagné des
élections et ces diviseurs qui avait le
soutien de monsieur mélenchon et
d'autres monsieur varoufakis qu'on
invite ici ou là à la fête de l'humanité
c'est quand même pouvoir quand même que
monsieur kerviel ancien trader et
monsieur varoufakis le dandy des
universités anglo saxonnes
tout ça pour dire qu'ils ont été
sanctionnés oui que ceux qui veulent la
gauche efficace dans ce peuple grec sans
vous dire eh bien ils choisiront de
surmonter ce qu'ils proposent la
division je prends juste un exemple
parce que là on parle évidemment des
élections régionales
en cas de victoire du front national
dans l'une des possibles victoire du
front national dans l'une des deux
régions paquin nord faut-il retirer la
liste ps
écoutez nous ont dit vous n'êtes pas
suffisamment bien passé nous feront
d'abord chaque chose en son temps si
vous voulez bien nous sommes l'hypothèse
qu'en tant que loi mais c'est une
hypothèse - hypothèses dans lesquelles
je me place j'en suis voyez je suis pas
comme vous déjà à la veille du au soir
du premier tour moi je suis à la veille
du dépôt des listes
je dis que dans les jeux les jours qui
viennent et semaines qui viennent
l'ordre du jour de quelle sur lequel
nous devons travailler c'est d'amener la
gauche à se rassembler notamment parce
que je veux bien croire que dans
certaines régions il peut y avoir de la
diversité mais quand il ya un danger
aussi énorme aussi considérable que
celui du nord pas de calais picardie
d'un côté de paca de l'autre provence
alpes côte d'azur
là on devrait avoir sur moi comme 10
reste posée la nation quand même dans
les moralistes et bien il faudra la
question que nous posons c'est oui ou
non la gauche va-t-elle se rassembler et
se donner les moyens de faire fumer
assez au front national à prendre une
décision voilà bah écoutez nous ne
sommes pas au moment du dépôt des listes
est sûre il y aura ensuite un premier
tour et ensuite il y aura un deuxième
tour
maintenant notre position elle a
toujours été très claire nous voulons et
le premier ministre manuel valls l'a
rappelé encore hiver- soir nous ferons
tout pour faire battre le front national
c'est clair alors jean marie le guen ya
eu des élections municipales à noisy le
grand seine saint denis
des fiefs de la gauche la droite l'a
emporté d'une courte tête 33 voix de
plus ce qui a provoqué la colère de
claude bartolone sur france inter
écoutez ce qui me rend furieux c'est que
la gauche était largement majoritaires
sur nos élans près de 54% et c'est la
division de la gauche qui a offert cette
ville à la droite et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut avoir à
l'esprit à la fois la veille de ces
élections régionales mais aussi à la
veille des différentes rencontres
présidentielle et législatives qui
amèneront les français à devoir faire le
choix entre deux modèles de société
deux orientations économiques sociales
et environnementales alors noisy
aujourd'hui ailleurs peut-être de
masquer la gauche radicale est prête à
tout pour vous faire perdre ces
élections qu'est ce que vous dites
officielles appel aux électeurs gentil
regarder les résultats de cette
politique j'ai parlé de la grèce parlons
de loisirs ont par des global du local
mais c'est mais c'est très bien c'est
très bien c'est la vie et donc là c'est
aussi la démonstration ou conduit le
sectarisme la division elle
antisocialisme primaire qui anime un
certain nombre de gens c'est je pense
qu'il y à une partie non pas alors
d'ailleurs cette liste vous savez qui
s'est maintenue et a perdu un tiers de
ses voix entre les deux tours
les gens ont dit mais bon moi je suis
plutôt critique mais jusqu'où on va
aller est ce que c'est
est-ce que ça ira mieux pour les gens à
noisy-le-grand quand la droite sera
revenu bon d'un certain prix dans leur
vrai ment dans leur sectarisme dans leur
enfermement intellectuel ont créé cette
défaite mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de français de sensibilité de gauche qui
se disent mais qui peuvent être critique
vis-à-vis de la situation vis-à-vis de
l'action du parti socialiste moi je je
n'ai pas je ne demande pas la
caporalisation de toute la gauche jeudi
sachons nous rassembler voilà et sachant
nous rassembler c'est valable
évidemment à la lecture de
noisy-le-grand on voit que l'alternative
c'est pas la gauche de la gauche la
gauche de la gauche
pour l'instant malheureusement elle
n'est que qu' elle ne gagne pas elle ne
fait elle n'avance pas elles ne font que
trébucher la gauche pour faire gagner la
droite quand même bien
je devrais pas être son rôle a priori
pas parce que même si elle est critique
aussi en interne sur même des ministres
sur emmanuel macron notamment les
députés socialistes étaient réunis en
séminaire le ministre de l'économie
emmanuel macron est venu leur rendre
visite après des déclarations qui ont
mis un petit peu le feu l'accueil a
commenté
comment peut-on dire un petit peu frais
regarder des propos qui ne passe
toujours pas les députés ont réservé un
accueil pour le moins mitigé à emmanuel
macron il ya quelques jours le ministre
de l'économie avait remis en cause le
statut des fonctionnaires
de quoi soulever un tollé pour une
partie de la gauche pour ce frondeur il
doit quitter le gouvernement quand on
lui dit nous on a des électeurs ou des
concitoyens qui pensent pas exactement
de cette manière il ya une gauche qui ne
se retrouvent pas dans un certain nombre
de propos
écoute poliment mais c'est pas ça qui me
fera changer d'avis parce que il procède
d'une forme de certitude qu'on connaît
bien en france et qui est celle d'une
certaine élite signe d'une fracture
persistantes au sein des socialistes
seule la moitié des parlementaires
étaient présents au séminaire de rentrée
de ce matin à la sortie emmanuel macron
fait néanmoins bonne figure c'était un
très bon moment de des changes de
pédagogie pour redonner du sens à notre
action collective à 20 mois de la
présidentielle c'est un cordon sanitaire
qui s'organise autour du gouvernement
didier guillaume et de ceux pour qui la
solidarité avec les écus tiff doit
primer ceux qui sont appelés les
frondeurs aujourd'hui sont trop râleur
sont plus frondeurs que râleurs et moi
j'appelle à la responsabilité collective
au moment où tous nos amis tous les
socialistes sont en campagne pour les
élections régionales
il n'est pas l'heure de se regarder le
nombril mais de parler aux français
pendant la réunion qui s'est déroulée à
huis clos
manuel valls a recadré son ministre mais
aussi les frondeurs une façon pour le
premier ministre de rappeler son rang de
chef de la majorité
emmanuel macron et bien lors de sa
rentrée politique martine aubry a
profité de deux tiers pour dire ce
qu'elle pensait de lui écouter macron
comment vous dire
ras-le-bol voilà ras-le-bol voilà c'est
le ministre de l'économie
il faut qu'il mette tous sont son
énergie qui est grande il sans doute ses
talents à accélérer la croissance et
l'emploi
et moi je dois dire je supporte de moins
en moins à la fois l'arrogance et
notamment sur les fonctionnaires pour un
ancien fonctionnaire certes devenu
banquier d'affaires mais quand même un
ancien fonctionnaire qui s'est sans
doute qu'en période de crise on n'a
jamais eu autant besoin des
fonctionnaires revenons d'abord sur les
propos d'emmanuel macron donc d'abord
sur les fonctionnaires et puis hier à
londres dans un sac privé il a remis un
peu les pieds dans le plat en dix ans
les jeunes générations veulent devenir
entrepreneur pas fonctionnaires est-ce
que c'est volontaire qui sait ce qu'il
dit écoutez est ce que on est dans une
france où il est
on est dans l'indignation dans le
politiquement correct supposés non je
pense qu'il faut avoir une certaine
forme de liberté de parole de discussion
est ce que ceux qui étaient me
semble-t-il maladroit dans les propos d'
emmanuel macron c'est qu' il pouvait
laissait pas penser en tant que ministre
qu'il y avait un agenda guy ouvrait une
discussion sur le statut des
fonctionnaires ce qui n'est pas le cas
donc c'est pourquoi manuel valls l'a
rappelé que l'agenda du gouvernement
était déjà d'ailleurs très chargé avec
la réforme du statut des fonctionnaires
voilà donc ce n'est pas à l'agenda de la
gauche aujourd'hui voilà pour le reste
pour marquer le groupe via le wii
écoutez moi c'est des propos on voit
bien c'est un peu des postures c'est
parce je trouve que ça ne fait pas du
bien
je veux dire si le but c'est de faire
avancer la gauche alors je pense qu'on
s'est trompé avec ce type de réaction
voilà et moi je veux rester dans l'idée
tu ne veux critiquer personne ni ce qui
est je ne veux pas du bien les critiques
ne fait pas du bien je suis pas là pour
critiquer les critiqueurs enfin elle dit
l'aîné peut-être mais je rappelle à tout
le monde qu'il faut essayer jeu on en
parlait il ya quelques instants de
rassembler voilà ce qu'elle donne à ce
que personne ne va exister en étant en
s'autoproclamant plus gentil plus
sympathique que l'autre apprenons à être
tous ensemble si nous ne faisons pas de
diversion une petite question sur la fin
quand elle dit macron ça ça vous choque
cette manière d'interpeller où je pense
que dans l'étonnant dans dans l'époque
actuelle effectivement les responsables
politiques doivent montrer comment
dirais-je des formes extérieures de
considération tout en étant extrêmement
sur le fond chacun doit défendre ses
idées mais que jeudi à des moments il ya
des formes pour le faire et voilà est-ce
que tout ça nous a fait avancer je ne le
crois pas donc elles ne rassemblent pas
c'est ce que vous dites je pense que les
critiqueurs
voilà je critique les critiqueurs à
passer un tout autre sujet reparler de
la course aux primaires vous savez qui a
lieu chez les républicains et une
proposition de françois fillon qui a
fait quand même beaucoup de bruit
l'ancien premier ministre appelle à
faire sauter le tabou des statistiques
ethniques aux basses avec jennifer se
mais c'est la loi informatique et
liberté de 1978 qui interdit la collecte
de données à caractère ethnique une
interdiction confirmée par le conseil
constitutionnel en 2007
la france fait presque figure
d'exception en europe où certains pays
n'hésitent pas à sonder leurs citoyens
sur leur appartenance ethnique
c'est le cas notamment en angleterre où
cinq catégories comme blancs métis ou
encore angles et noir sont proposés dans
le recensement pas de débat non plus aux
pays bas et en grèce où les relevés sur
l'origine nationale sont autorisés en
france avant françois fillon ces
statistiques avaient été réclamés en
2009 par nicolas sarkozy et manuel valls
deux commissions parlementaires avaient
alors été créés comme le rappelle le
démographe hervé le bras et deux
commissions ont rendu des rapports qui
sont circonstancié et qui pour
l'ensemble recommande de ne pas faire de
statistiques ethniques au niveau des
recensements de l'est permettent au
niveau des études de chercheurs et qui
diverge simplement sur la possibilité
d'en faire sur des grandes enquêtes des
pin's ide en début d'année la sénatrice
écologiste
esther benbassa et son collègue l'avait
public un jean rené lecerf pro d'une
réforme des formulaires de recensement
incluant le lieu de naissance et la
nationalité antérieure
une mesure pour lutter contre les
discriminations territoriales et
sociales qui pour l'heure est restée
lettre morte
jean-marie le guen je présenterai un
projet de loi en ce sens on sauve en
2010 il faut relancer le débat sur les
statistiques ethniques qui a dit ça je
lance hameçon plusieurs intérêts annuels
mal voilà tabou ou pas les statistiques
ethniques bien écoutez je suis en
désaccord avec cette proposition de
manuel valls
personnellement je suis d'accord avec
c'était une proposition qu'il faisait
lorsqu'il était
pour les primaires voilà dans le cadre
des primaires du parti socialiste n'a
pas été retenu par un parti socialiste
et personnellement si vous me demandez
mon avis j'étais en désaccord avec ce
qu'il disait et je suis en accord avec
ce que dit hervé le bras qui me paraît
très juste c'est dire qu'il faut laisser
aux chercheurs la possibilité de faire
des travaux de sociologie
d'anthropologie mais je ne pense pas que
l'êta et que l'organisation sociale de
notre pays doit commencer à rentrer dans
les logiques anglo saxon qui consiste
tout simplement on le sait bien c'est ce
que c'est la base même du
communautarisme
donc je pense que sa part pour de bons
principes je fais pas de mauvais procès
d'intention à à françois fillon ni à
manuel valls qui ayant développé cette
position là je comprends qu'il ya un
souci de décrire la réalité il y a le
souci qui a un petit peu aux journées il
ya le souci de dire par exemple que il y
a des ghettos de les objective et avec
des enquêtes statistiques on pourrait
dire par exemple grigny pour prendre cet
exemple et bien il y a objectivement il
n'y a pas une répartition juste sur le
territoire
donc on voit bien pourquoi ces
statistiques je l'intérêt que pourrait
avoir cette statistique
néanmoins je pense que nous n'avons pas
besoin pour objectiver quelque chose
prend des voix là et que ça pourrait
donner l'idée que nous nous appartenons
les uns et les autres à des communautés
d'origine vous voyez je suis breton et
basques alors qu'est-ce que je dois dire
je suis breton je suis basque français
bon et on doit me juger alors que je
suis née à paris est ce qu'on doit me
juger comme un parisien comme un breton
comme un basque comme un française comme
ça on en finit par et dans le ce qui est
l'esprit républicain français me
semble-t-il ça pourrait induire des
conséquences sur la manière dont nous
regardons les uns les autres
non je ne trouve pas positive par contre
la recherche des chercheurs parce que il
faut pas être non plus je disais
politiquement correct tout à l'heure on
pourrait dire faux cul pour prendre
cette ce mot absolument trivial mais qui
dit bien ce qui veut dire il faut qu'on
puisse dire les choses aussi parce qu'il
ya des choses qui peuvent aller sans
tabou n'est pas ta bourse
vous avez raison de me reprendre et
prendra mots français beaucoup élégant
que celui employé
je vous remercie de votre aide c'est
sans doute une aide tout à fait utile au
regard des reportages que j'avais eus
précédemment qui me manque le m'amener à
avoir un langage plus vers épuisé
presque 7
il ya et donc vous avez raison les
chercheurs doivent pouvoir chercher mais
la france ne doit pas intégrer la
problématique des communautés d'origines
multiples on a bien compris que c'est
mon point de vue on a compris depuis
celui du gouvernement aujourd'hui à
aujourd'hui a dit mercredi l'actualité
politique les républicains se sont donné
rendez-vous à reims pour leurs journées
parlementaires
tout le monde était là nicolas sarkozy
le premier avec pour perspective l'unité
au moins jusqu'aux régionales germans
andrieu thibault le floch et louis
sybille étaient sur place
revenu sur le devant de la scène
politique il ya moins d'un an nicolas
sarkozy mise aujourd'hui tout sur les
militants le président des républicains
n'est pas officiellement candidat aux
primaires
alors en attendant un message clé
l'unité nous ne sommes pas dans le temps
des primaires
nous sommes dans le temps des régionales
et je ferai respecter ce calendrier
non pas parce que c'est beau l'intérêt
ou l'intérêt de tel ou tel mais parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre choix
l'unité comme seule perspective avec un
programme ou un socle commun sur tous
les thèmes sécurité logement ou encore
immigration tout sera désormais trancher
et voté par les militants
un programme commun mais pas
contraignant il y aura un programme les
républicains c'est légitime c'est même
un devoir que la formation politique est
un programme
ce programme bien évidemment ne sera pas
une obligation pour l'ensemble des
candidats primaires c'est pas un
concours d'élégance
la primaire c'est un concours d'idées de
projets pour le pays
c'est une manière de présenter une
vision du pays qui doit convaincre le
plus grand nombre de français
et ce à la primaire une primaire où tout
le monde aurait le même projet n'aurait
strictement aucun intérêt
prochain objectif 300 mille adhérents
avant la fin de l'année une base
électorale prioritaire pour nicolas
sarkozy mais pas suffisante en cas de
succès la primaire de la droite et du
centre en 2016 pourrait mobiliser entre
2 et 3 millions de votants
alors une question sur ces primaires que
le parti socialiste serait bien aussi
est ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
chose
ou c'est au contraire un piège le pam
mois général mais écoutez je pense qu'il
n'y a pas d'heure c'est pas une règle
absolue in abstracto c'est je pense que
c'est une question de
culture politique de chaque formation
politique de moments voilà donc là ils
ont décidé de faire une primaire je sais
pas s'ils vont s'y prendre
comme il faut il s'y prend il copie
énormément la manière dont ces avait
fait le parti socialiste je constate que
pour le parti socialiste avait
globalement bien marché hees avait
d'ailleurs permis que le projet de
françois hollande soit au delà de la
personne c'était aussi le projet qui
était le sien qui était différent du
projet départ du projet du parti et la
forêt donc je passais pense et je pense
que je pense qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui lors division son fonds sont
très puissantes
moi je vois par exemple monsieur sarkozy
qui viennent nous expliquer qu'ils
n'étaient que en campagne régionale il a
fait un petit coup de force là en une
semaine qu'on a une espèce de blitzkrieg
sur la problématique de l'immigration il
faut que tu peux bien c'est vraiment
c'est quand même d un problème d une des
questions fondamentales y en a six ou
sept
mais c'est une des questions
fondamentales de du temps de l'époque
des années qui viennent donc de
l'élection présidentielle et il a envoyé
un questionnaire auquel donc il a forcé
la main en quelque sorte en quelques
jours à ses militants et surtout à tous
les autres concurrents grand potentiel
pour écrire en main ce que répond
monsieur juppé que j'aurais pu en tout
cas avec lequel je peux moi
personnellement très largement convergé
sur les réponses de monsieur juppé sont
à l'opposé de ce que dit monsieur
sarkozy et du questionnaire et mai mais
absolument
mais si vous voulez c'est un débat qui
me semble-t-il mené tel qu'il est mené à
l'heure actuelle par monsieur sarkozy et
je pense parce que ça correspond à la
réalité de ce qui se passe à droite et
dans le pays plus largement
parce que moi je ne suis plus un homme
de gauche mais je m'intéresse à ce qui
se passe à droite pas simplement pour
les combattre parce que mais simplement
pour entendre les idées du débat d'idées
et puis bon c'est pas des ennemis ce
sont
des adversaires des concurrents bon et
quand je vois la nature du débat je me
dis que parti comme c'est parti
il y a des divergences qui sont
absolument fondamentales
vous prenez après jeudi nicolas sarkozy
bien sûr j'ai longtemps vous prenez donc
cette question de l'immigration est
essentielle
ce que dit juppé ce que dit sarkozy
ça n'a rien à voir mais rien à voir
c'est pas que c'est différent ça aix est
opposée sur l'éducation
j'attends ce que dira monsieur sarkozy
puisqu'il ne l'a pas dit par contre j'ai
lu ce qu'a dit monsieur juppé ce que dit
monsieur juppé est très largement
convergents
même s'il ya des critiques et c'est avec
ce super jeu je le dis sur la sphère de
de l'éducation quand il dit qu'il faut
un sacraliser le budget de l'éducation
deux maîtres d'ailleurs une rémunération
supplémentaire pour les trois refusé ce
qu'on appelle globalement l'académisme
c'est à dire je pose le c'est très
important
c'est très important c'est à dire
maintient le maintien du statu quo ante
et c'est à dire bon il fait une idée il
est à l'envers de toutes les critiques
qui ont été faites contre le projet de
najat vallaud belkacem et donc je
constate qu il des signes
une politique qui à mon avis est une
politique de droit quand on passera sur
les questions économiques et sociales
notamment mais qui est exactement l
inverse de ce que dit monsieur ça fait
quand on prend sujet petit sujet au sein
des séries on voit bien que monsieur
juppé et monsieur sarkozy sont sur la
position strictement opposée à celle de
monsieur fillon et avoir avant celle de
monsieur le maire
donc vous voyez si vous voulez que se
dessinent des cartes qui ne sont pas
simplement des options différentes dans
un menu mais qui sont quand même qu'ils
dessinent qui dessine une vraie coupure
à l'intérieur des candidats d'avoir un
peu de temps mais je voudrais quand même
avoir votre position nicolas sarkozy
c'est très intéressant j'ai lu propose
pendant les journées parlementaires de
revenir sur le cumul des mandats
oui ça montre quoi deux choses
premièrement qui n'a pas compris les
aspirations à une certaine forme de
modernité deuxièmement au cas où il leur
vaguement compris puisque tout ce qui
n'est pas du tout impossible
il s'assoit dessus pour faire du
clientélisme électoral
il sait bien que pour dans le combat des
primaires
l'intérêt des parlementaires ce sont des
relais d'opinion relativement important
et un certain nombre de parlementaires
par habitude par facilité par tout ce
qu'on veut veulent conserver demande à
rioz t il en rit avec moi vous serez
servi je vous permettrait de continuer
comme avant
clientélisme c'est du clientélisme
politique il n'est pas le seul et je je
je je ne méprise pas de temps en temps
l'envi de satisfaire les parlementaires
mais là on voit bien qu'ils sacrifient
des éléments importants de la
modernisation de la vie politique au
profit d'un clientélisme
alors on va passer avant des raisons
électorales on va passer à mercredi si
vous le voulez bien jours de sommet
extraordinaire à bruxelles 120 mille
réfugiés seront accueillis et répartis
dans les 28 pays européens un accord a
finalement été pris malgré l'opposition
de quatre pays de l'est
sophie normand à peine conclu un accord
laborieux sur la répartition des
réfugiés l'union européenne veut freiner
leur afflux autre versant de sa réponse
à la question de la crise migratoire
aujourd'hui
mais nous parlons de millions de
réfugiés potentiels tentant de se rendre
en europe pas de miser pour faire face à
cette situation les dirigeants européens
réfléchissent à deux axes d'abord le
renforcement durable des frontières
extérieures de l'ue ensuite l aide
humanitaire pour endiguer un flux de
migrants sans précédent il devrait
s'engager à verser un milliard d'euros
aux agences de l'onu qui viennent en
aide aux réfugiés dans les pays voisins
de la syrie
c'est en turquie et en jordanie c'est au
liban que les aides doivent être
apportées le plus vite possible pour que
les réfugiés puissent être
accueilli comme ils le sont
tout ne soit pas de tenter de venir
jusqu en europe où ils risquent leur vie
des mesures urgentes et un plan concret
revenir françois hollande a déjà annoncé
des aides supplémentaires de la france
pour assurer selon ses mots un devoir de
solidarité et de responsabilité
est ce que pour vous les forts français
à la hauteur est ce que la france en
fait assez ce qu'elle pourrait pas en
faire plus que ce comparativement à
d'autres pays comme l'allemagne sur
cette question des réfugiés de bon nous
en faisons déjà beaucoup
ces derniers mois ces dernières années
nous allons faire encore plus nous
prenons une part importante de la
solidarité à la fois à l'intérieur des
frontières pour l'accueil des réfugiés
du droit d'asile mais aussi à
l'extérieur de façon j'allais dire
préventive c'est à dire que nous venons
de participer avec les autres pays
européens l'union européenne a donné de
l'argent à des pays comme la turquie
comme le liban comme la jordanie qui
comme vous le savez on des camps de
réfugiés syriens tout à fait
considérable nous le faisons par
humanisme
par souci humanitaire mais nous le
faisons aussi parce que nous souhaitons
que ces populations ne quitte pas le
moyen orient et reste moyen-orient enfin
la france c'est une autre dimension
elle intervient aujourd'hui pour
rétablir de la sécurité et de la paix
dans plusieurs régions du monde car est
à l'initiative elle et je pense qu'elle
est profondément à l'initiative et je
veux dire que ce qui s'est passé à
bruxelles et en ligne complètement avec
le discours que nous tenons depuis plus
d'un an et demi sur ces questions et il
s'agit pas de faire du cocorico mais
c'est l'orientation de la politique
française qui est respect du droit
d'asile mais maîtrise des flux
migratoires qui est aujourd'hui la
position européenne est en tout cas
celle pour laquelle les rites magiques
ils sont actuellement en france
statistique venue de lille de frotter
préfecture pratiquement un réfugié sur
10 s'en va aujourd'hui une fois qu'il
est arrivé en france il repart tout de
suite direction l'allemagne c'est
quelque chose qui vous amène à un
commentaire to dire que les français je
pense qu'ils ne veulent pas rester sur
le territoire français ils savent qu'en
france il y a une problématique
démographique
cela contredit qu'on perd dans le
discours qui a été tenu par certains
réactionnaires
de droite ou d'extrême droite et avec
surtout l'extrême droite tous ceux qui
ont expliqué que la france était un
aspirateur immigration en raison de ses
prestations sociales
la réalité c'est que c'est faux puisque
je venais de le décrire deuxièmement
chacun voit ce qui se passe à calais
c'est à dire des gens qui souhaitent
aller travailler en grande bretagne
pourquoi parce que le droit du travail
en grande bretagne et plus permissif
plus souffle compris parce que les
salaires étant moins élevé facilite
l'insertion des gens qui n'ont pas de
qualification et peu d'insertion
professionnelle quand vous allez
travailler en grande bretagne pour
mettons 800 euros ou en allemagne
puisqu'il ya aussi cette facilité en
allemagne
eh bien vous mettez un premier pied dans
l'activité professionnelle
alors qu'en france pour des raisons de
défense de notre structure sociale nous
avons nous n'acceptons pas ce type de
permissivité de l'emploi et donc ils
vont chercher en allemagne là où il ya
des problèmes démographiques aussi c'est
à dire que et puis à l'appel de manama
étaient à bord dont là ils vont là où il
ya un petit peu d'emplois il ya des
emplois y compris les emplois que pour
l'instant et que que nous n'acceptons
pas devoir développer sur notre
territoire
c'est à 10 ans de l'emploi qui sont
faits ces fameux mini jobs qui sont
acceptés en allemagne en grande bretagne
et qui ne sont pas enfoncés amène à
parler évidemment de l'emploi en france
avec voyez que parts égales sur notre
jeu et social a des effets que certains
économistes etc a fortiori certains
hommes politiques libéraux oublie de
rappeler c'est à dire que c'est parce
que nous avons un cadre et un salaire
minimum et qu' il y à aussi
déjouer ce pensum jeudi on parle de
chiffres du chômage
c'est un chiffre qui repart à la hausse
un peu plus vingt mille demandeurs
d'emploi en plus au mois d'août de
mauvais chiffres
c'est ce qu'a dit en tout cas le premier
ministre l'écoutent sont des mauvais
chiffres
bien sûr pourquoi le chômage stagne ou
baisse peu ou augmentent comme ce mois
ci plutôt comme le mois dernier c'est
pour ça que nous réformons mais ce n'est
pas suffisant donc il faut davantage se
mobiliser davantage réforme et se
demander pourquoi il ya trois cent mille
emplois qui ne sont pas pourvus la
nouvelle ministre du travail
mais il ya mieux comme brive en faire
une priorité faire mieux encore mon
l'emploi des jeunes pour les chômeurs de
longue durée
donc c'est une tâche mais moi j'ai une
conviction c'est que nous allons réussir
alors j'accueille tout de suite sur ce
plateau jim jarrassé qui va parler dans
un instant avec vous jean marie le guen
une question sur réaction à ce qu'a dit
manuel valls est ce que c'est la méthode
coué il est très volontariste dit que
non si on va réussir ne peut pas de dire
que l'on a tout essayé dans la lutte
contre le chômage
donc les continue il va continuer à
réformer de l'autre côté les choix qui
ont été faits nous sommes nous avons la
conviction que ces choix porteront leurs
fruits
j'allais dire même ils portent leurs
fruits qu'est ce qui se passe très
rapidement premièrement les entreprises
retrouvent démarche est potentiellement
vont investir et donc après créer de
l'emploi
premièrement et deuxièmement la création
d'emplois et la plus importante j'aime
bien la création d'emplois ce qui se
passe c'est que la démographie française
étant ce qu'elle est nous n'arrivons le
train de la création d'emplois n'arrive
pas à dépasser le train de l'afflux de
jeunes sur le marché de l'emploi
j'en ai la conviction
vous avez toute la conviction va passer
de la wii mais il faut avoir des
convictions je sais une chose c'est que
le statu quo ça c'est sûr ça serait la
continuation du déclin et donc il faut
bouger
est-ce qu'il faut tout rompre est-ce
qu'il faut tout casser comme le propose
à droite je ne le crois pas on en
parlait il ya quelques instants sur le
modèle social ses avantages ses
inconvénients genre peuvent exister
donc je pense qu'il ne faut pas tout
casser je pense qu'il faut réformer
je pense que nous que les réformes que
nous mettons en avant dans le sens de
cela mais je n'oublie pas que nous
sommes avec une industrie qui a été
profondément à la fin du quinquennat et
comme a dit martine aubry
ce vendredi matin si le chômage baisse
françois hollande peut être candidat
mais pourquoi si simplement c'est parti
le bris qui le dit ce n'est pas moi
françois hollande sera notre candidat il
n'y a pas besoin de mettre des six bon
ça c'est dit aussi a passé à la loupe du
scad bonjour jamie cade focaccia bonjour
jean marie le guen
bonjour on vient de voir des images de
manuel valls sur le plateau de des
paroles et des actes vous étiez présent
et vous n'étiez pas seul puisque
l'ensemble où la quasi-totalité du
gouvernement était sur le plateau
c'est une image qui nous a rappelé qu'à
une autre image celle des conférences de
presse de françois hollande à l'elysée
c'était quoi hier la conférence du
vice-président non ces deux choses
différentes
lorsque il ya le gouvernement qui est
présent à l'elysée c'est une forme de
respect vis-à-vis des institutions et du
président de la république
si nous étions hier soir tous sur le
plateau c'était pour montrer que nous
sommes une équipe et que effectivement
un gouvernement c'est une colle
important ce moment de montrer cette
cohésion il y avait dix façons de
travailler
non ya pas de dissension il ya des
façons de travailler
de manuel valls qui est je crois une des
plus collective que nous avions connu
chez les premiers ministres ces
dernières années jean marc ayrault avait
fait des choses aussi dans ce sens mais
là on le voit bien et d'ailleurs ça
avait été notée c'est important qu'il ya
un gouvernement qu'ils sentent qu'il
agit dans un collectif ça évite quelques
quoique vous avez donc hier soir sur le
plateau de télé vous êtes souvent sur
les plateaux d'ailleurs en cette rentrée
politique
et vous en profitez pour relayer les
messages du gouvernement est tous un peu
pour cibler vos des cibles favorites
il y en a deux céline cécile duflot et
jean luc mélenchon dont vous avez encore
parler aujourd'hui
un proche de françois hollande dit dans
le parisien ce matin il ferait un beau
couple
vous êtes d'avoir les deux qui deux mois
et de saisie duflot et jean luc
mélenchon
d'abord je voudrais dire que je suis un
de ceux qui est le plus présent sur les
débats politiques face au front national
et parmi tous mes amis de l'extrême
gauche au la gauche du parti socialiste
à ceux qui se prétendent etc
j'aimerais qu'il soit un petit peu plus
contre la droite ou contre le front
national
je veux bien faire l'exemple de mon
temps de jeu comme on dit je suis plus
souvent en contrôle front national et
contre la droite que beaucoup d'autres
et que vous êtes au travail que d'être
contre vieux beaucoup d'autres moi
l'essentiel de mon temps c'est contre le
front national en général quand il ya un
débat à faire dans le front national je
me retrouve souvent à ces sols c'est
plutôt moi qu'on envoie bon et donc
voilà mes donc front national je les
verrai alors il ne manque
il m'arrive aussi et je viens à votre
question de me désole des aventures
individuelles et les postures sectaire
et donc je vous réponds à l'évidence
cécile duflot trouve de plus en plus de
charme à jean luc mélenchon
et donc je le veux pas anticiper bah
écoute et non moi c'est comment
dirais-je c'est un style rétro mais si
ça plaît à cécile duflot
tant mieux j'avais cru qu'elle était
plutôt pour des choses plus plus moderne
mais une autre de vos cibles favorites
sont les frondeurs à moi qu'on doive
peut-être maintenant les appelait les
râleurs c'est le nouveau mot d'ordre
qu'on a entendu sa semaine non plus
effectivement à leur relation de parent
des râleurs c'est un bon sur nous et ça
correspond plus tôt ce même monsieur
gentil je trouve
alors moi je suis plutôt de tempérament
râleurs au signalement et un commentaire
sur ce voyage de député en syrie a fait
ce week-end 3-2 députés de la majorité
se rendent en syrie pour ce qu'ils
présentent comme un voyage humanitaire
alors on recompte des minorités
syriennes menacé par des ch est-ce que
le gouvernement approuve ce déplacement
non vous le savez nous sommes nous
pensons que nous n'avons plus de liens
diplomatiques avec le gouvernement
syrien s'est d'ailleurs monsieur fillon
qui avait
suspendu notre ambassade à damas donc
nous n'approuvons pas évidemment est ce
qu'il faut les sanctionner
dans le cas du parti socialiste et de
fougères qui est mauvais il faut prendre
on est sur autre chose d'abord gérard
bapt essaye d'être je pense que je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ce qu'il fait
mais on voit bien que gérard bapt essaye
d'être positif c'est-à-dire d'apporter
quelque chose je ne suis pas d'accord
avec lui mais il est dans un état
d'esprit positif
il n'est pas dans la il n'y a pas une
posture de critiques il a une posture
d'apport d'interrogation l'inter de se
servir les affaires je suis je ne suis
finalement n'avait pas jusque là non je
ne vais pas jusque là je dis je donne
acte à gérard bapt de sa bonne foi
je ne suis pas d'accord mais pas
d'accord du tout mais c'est pas la peine
d'en rajouter
nous sommes extrêmement clair nous ne
considérons que le goût que bachar el
assad est au moins autant un problème
qu'une solution
et nous n'allons pas là dedans il se
trouve que gérard bas puisque vous
parlez de lui et est quelqu'un que je
respecte et par ailleurs quelqu'un qui
s'est beaucoup investi au liban qui l'a
beaucoup de l'appréciation de ce pays
c'est un pays compliqué bon voilà alors
maintenant qu'ils soient un peu absorbé
en quelque sorte par tout ce qu'il a vu
dans cette région du monde
je le constate je ne suis pas d'accord
avec lui je compte me l'a prêté encore
trois ans
ça n'empêche que j'estime que ce il
pense faire quelque chose qui va dans le
sens des intérêts et de la france et de
la gauche je pense qu'ils se trompent
c'est long et on va terminer cette
émission avec les rêves d'anne hidalgo
qui veut redécouper paris la maire de
paris veut fusionner notamment le
département et la commune c'est le pari
d'anne hidalgo reprendre la main sur la
capitale en récupérant les pouvoirs
aujourd'hui dévolues à l'état car paris
n'est pas une ville comme les autres à
la différence du reste de la france dans
la ville des lumières
le préfet se substituer au maire sur
certains points la voirie la régulation
du stationnement ou encore certaines
questions d'urbanisme
autant de points de crispation entre la
mer et l'état qui serait alors vite
évacuer en cas de récupération de ses
compétences par l'hôtel de ville
deuxième volonté d'anne hidalgo
fusionner la ville de paris le
département mettant ainsi fin à une
autre singularité de la capitale
l'objectif est de réduire le
millefeuille administratif
al'approche de la création du grand
paris enfin autre idée soufflée dans la
missive adressée à françois hollande et
manuel valls
la modification de la carte des
arrondissements parisiens
anne hidalgo espère ainsi rééquilibrer
les écarts de population entre les
quartiers pour une meilleure répartition
des services pour parvenir à cette
refondation du statut de la capitale la
maire de paris compte sur l'examen d'un
projet de loi au parlement début 2016 il
nous reste une minute une seule question
est ce qu'un projet de loi sera déposé
au parlement pour modifier le statut de
paris je n'en sais rien pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de projet de loi ya pas de
rien du tout et je dis moi alors
d'autant jolie auto plus nettement que
j'ai un conflit d'intérêts c'est que je
suis moi même conseillé que dans le
cadre de la préparation des municipales
de 2010 j'avais fait des propositions
qui allaient dans le sens et même un
petit peu plus loin d'ailleurs de ce que
dit alan hidalgo licencient mais en tant
que mini je peux vous dire il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas connaissance
d'un projet de loi sur le sujet
maintenant ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
n'aura pas lieu mais aujourd'hui
alors il n'y a pas de loi et il n'ya pas
évidemment d'inscription à l'agenda
parlementaire qui est déjà
potentiellement extrêmement chargé
s'agissant du printemps 2016
maintenant on peut toujours
éventuellement modifier cet agenda plus
favorable ou pas le gouvernement n'a pas
de position encore aujourd'hui parce que
on a lu dans la presse les propositions
j'allais dire de philosophie qui est un
petit peu autour de tout ça après il
faut l'écrire faut un débat vérité ça
c'est les rythmes et ba ba écoute et où
j'en suis convaincue par ce que j'y suis
favorable et moi à titre personnel je me
suis je vais pas dire le contraire mais
le gouvernement aujourd'hui n'a pas de
position il n'a pas débattu du sujet il
n'a pas instruit le sujet et il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui de projets de loi alors
qu'ils nous aient été présentés
merci beaucoup jean marie le guen aurait
posé deux questions avec beaucoup trop
chez merci beaucoup
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine dans
par le break tôt merci
oh